تبعنا طبعا مشاهد جدا قاسيه
ومؤلمه هل من معلومات مفصله بشكل اكبر عن
هذه المشاهد التي
تابعناها نعم هذه الصور هي في الواقع قبل
سبعه ايام من الان تقريبا حينما كانت
تتواجد قوات الاحتلال في منطقه اليرموك
وملعب اليرموك هذه المنطقه وهذا المربع
الذي كان ياوي عشرات الاف النازحين بعد ما
هربوا من منطقه الشجاعيه او نزحوا عفوا من
منطقه الشجاعيه التي نفذت بها قوات
الاحتلال وتحولت الى مصرح عمليات بريه
لقوات الاحتلال فنزح تلك العائلات من
المناطق الشرقيه وايضا نزحت من المناطق
الشماليه الغربيه ل لمدينه غزه ومناطق
الشماليه الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه وهي منطقه
حي الزيتون كل هذه المناطق كانت بالتوازي
مصرح عمليات لقوات الاحتلال وا مما اضطر ل
المواطنون النزوح الى هذه المناطق لكن في
تاره وفجاه توجهت قوات الاحتلال الى هذذه
المنطقه التي تاوي عشرات الاف النازحين
وحاصرت هذه المنطقه التي هي تعتبر منطقه
ملعب اليرموك والمناطق المحيطه التي
تتواجد بها مدرستين حكوميتين ووزاره
التربيه والتعليم بالاضافه الى منطقه ابو
خضرا وكل المناطق المحاذيه التي كانت هي
بالاساس مكانا لاواء النازحين لكن قوات
الاحتلال حاصرت هذا المكان واجبرت الكثير
من النازحين على خ على خلع ملابسهم لكن
هذه الصوره لا تقتصر فقط على ملعب اليرموك
اينما تتواجد قوات الاحتلال ومن قبل في
المناطق الغربيه لهذه المنطقه مدرسه صلاح
الدين اجبرت الكثير من المواطنين على خلع
ملابسهم واضطر الكثير وصولا في ساعات
الليل الى هذه المنطقه منطقه مجمع الشفاء
وهم يرتدون فقط ملابس بسيطه جدا وا اضطر
اجبرهم اجبرتهم قوات الاحتلال على خلع
الملابس ضمن نطاق امني كما يدعي قوات
الاحتلال لكن بعد التف تفتيش لا يسمح
لهؤلاء المواطنون ارتداء ملابسهم من البرد
الشديد او السقيع مما تنفذ قوات الاحتلال
هذا الامر بمعامله لا انسانيه والكثير
منهم وصل الى هنا مضروبا بشكل مبرح من
قوات الاحتلال واخرين
وصلوا قوات الاحتلال اعدمت عائلاتهم امام
ناظريه ووثقنا هذا الامر تكرارا امام
الجمهور لكن قوات الاحتلال تستمر
بالمعامله اللا الانسانيه حتى بحق الاطفال
واعدمت ايضا الاطفال في من عائله عنان
اعدم الطفله او عفوا من عائله سالم اعدم
الطفله امام نظر عائلتها ولا لا تبرح قوات
الاحتلال عن التوقف من هذه المعاملات
والاجراءات اللا انسانيه مع المواطنين
الفلسطينيين في المناطق الغربيه لقطاع غزه
ويستمر هذا الفعل في الايام الاخيره ايضا
راينا ذلك ووصل بعض المواطنون من منطقه
ابو اسكندر يرتدون فقط ملابس بسيطه مشوا
كيلوات مترات طويله جدا وصولا الى مجمع
الشفاء الطبي في اجواء بارده جدا اقدامهم
عاريه لا يرتدون الا فقط قطعه بسيطه من
القماش تغطي المناطق او مناطق العوره
وصولا الى مجمع الشفاء الطبي هذا السلوك
مستمر من قوات الاحتلال في المناطق
الشماليه قطاع غزه واي منطقه يدخلها الجيش
الاسرائيلي يجبر المواطنون على هذا التصرف
دون رحمه ودون معامله او د او كما يدعي
الاحتلال انه يتعامل معامله انسانيه لكن
الصور تعكس هذا الامر وتعكس المعامله اللا
انسانيه التي تتصرف فيها جنود الاحتلال